Things are just starting to look up for Jorge, when the thing with the TV happened. He had just moved to a new town, started his life over, found some work, got a place. Years of searching around in vagueness were ending.
豪尔赫的生活才刚刚有了起色，电视上的那件事就发生了。他刚搬到一个新的城镇，重新开始了生活，找到了一份工作，也有了住处。多年来那种漂泊不定的状态终于要结束了。
It's going well. Like the way that I'm procrastinating now is by-- like doing work. You know? Coming into my home, I feel good. I'm paying bills relatively on time.
一切都很顺利。就像我现在拖延工作的方式，就是在做一些……你知道的，工作。回到家，我感觉很好。我付账单也比较准时。
He'd moved to New York City, which was scary. And walked into an apartment that real New Yorkers told him was a find-- a little studio in the East Village. One room. Good location. Cheap. And then one night he's sitting at his table, watching The Bachelorette on TV. And it's the episode where the bachelorette has whittled it down to four guys that she's going to pick one from, eventually. And she's in New York City visiting one of the potentials.
他搬到了纽约市，这让他感到害怕。他走进了一间公寓，老纽约人都说这可是个好地方——位于东村的一间小工作室。单间，地段好，还便宜。一天晚上，他坐在桌子旁，看着电视里的《单身女郎》（The Bachelorette）。那一集节目里，女主角已经从候选人中筛选出了最后四位，最终她会选出其中一位。此时她正在纽约市拜访其中一位潜在对象。
And you know, she goes out to dinner with his family. And they eat, and you know, they've got the shifty-eyed sister. And you know, like everybody's family acts the exact same way. You know?
你知道，她和他的家人一起出去吃饭。他们吃着饭，你知道的，那儿有个眼神闪烁的姐妹。你知道，每个人的家庭表现都一模一样。你懂吗？
Right.
没错。
And then they get in the limousine, and they decide to go back to his apartment. Now I'm on the edge of my seat. Because I moved to New York-- it's an enormous city. And I would be so excited if I could recognize the street. I would be so excited. It would just make me so happy. And so I'm totally-- I'm totally excited. So they get out of the limo, and he hugs her in the street. And they pan and they show a building. They show an awning. And it's my awning.
然后他们上了豪华轿车，决定回他的公寓。我现在紧张得坐不住了。因为我搬到了纽约——这是一个巨大的城市。如果我能认出那条街，我会非常兴奋。我会非常激动的。那会让我感到无比开心。所以我完全……我完全沉浸在兴奋之中。他们下了轿车，他在街上拥抱了她。镜头一转，拍到了那一栋楼。拍到了一个遮阳棚。那正是我的遮阳棚。
It's your building?
那是你的大楼吗？
It's my building. It's the awning to my building. It says the address. It says the street. It's-- you know-- it's possibly the only place in New York I actually know. (both laughing) And then he opens the door, and she comes in, and it's my lobby. You know? There's my lobby. There is the row of mailboxes, you know? And I'm just like-- I'm out of my chair. And I'm-- I can't talk. I'm like-- you know-- like pointing at the TV.
那是我的大楼。是我那栋楼的遮阳棚。上面写着门牌号。写着街道名。那是……你知道……那可能是纽约唯一一个我真正认识的地方。（两人大笑）然后他打开门，她走了进去，那就是我的门厅。你懂吗？那是我的门厅。那是一排信箱，你知道吗？我当时就像……我从椅子上跳了起来。我……我说不出话来。我一直在指着电视。
If it were me, I would think like, are they here right now? Like in the building?
要是我的话，我会想，他们现在就在这儿吗？就在这栋楼里？
You're too smart. I couldn't think. I was just like, aaah. [Ira laughs] You know? You know what I mean? I was just like-- I was just flabbergasted. It just couldn't be happening, you know?
你太聪明了。我当时根本没法思考。我只是觉得，啊。（艾拉笑）你懂吗？你知道我的意思吗？我当时只是……我完全被惊呆了。这根本不可能发生，你懂吗？
He watches them take the elevator up to the fourth floor. Jorge lives on the fifth. They walk down the hallway door. And then Jorge realizes something else.
他看着他们乘电梯上了四楼。豪尔赫住在五楼。他们沿着走廊走到门口。接着，豪尔赫意识到了另一件事。
You know, he doesn't just live in the city as me. He doesn't live on the same street as me. He doesn't just live in the same building as me. He basically lives in my apartment. He lives in the exact same apartment. This exact same layout.
你知道，他不只是和我住在同一个城市。他不只是住在同一条街上。他不只是住在同一栋大楼里。他基本上就住在我的公寓里。他住的是完全相同的户型。
So wait a second. So the camera goes inside this apartment, and you see your apartment, basically.
等等，等一下。所以摄像机进了那个公寓，你看到的基本上就是你的公寓。
A much better version of my apartment. His is much better. The walls are wider. The place is cleaner. The furniture is nicer. He has a half wall. He's got a half wall.
那是我公寓的一个升级版本。他的那间好得多。墙壁更宽，地方更干净，家具也更好。他有一面半隔断墙。他有半面墙。
A half wall with brick, glass, blocks?
用砖块、玻璃块砌成的半隔断墙吗？
It's like drywall, you know? But it seems like it has some sort of counter top kind of thing on it.
就像是石膏板，你知道吗？但看起来上面好像还有某种台面之类的东西。
And at that moment Jorge gets this flash. He is not really doing all that well. His apartment is a kind of dump, compared to this guy who's on TV. Plus he's watching Trista Rehn, the bachelorette, on TV, looking uncomfortable in his apartment on national TV. In fact, she bails on the guy.
就在那一刻，豪尔赫脑子里闪过一个念头。他其实过得并不怎么样。比起电视上那个家伙，他的公寓简直是个垃圾堆。更何况他正在电视上看着那个单身女郎特丽斯塔·雷恩（Trista Rehn），在全美观众面前表现出一副对他公寓很不满的样子。事实上，她最后甩了那家伙。
She leaves the apartment, and they cut to like that head-on interview. You know? And she's looking into the camera. And she says, I've dated guys with really bad apartments before. I can't judge him on that. I have to-- I have to find out why he feels like he can live in an apartment like this.
她离开了公寓，镜头切换到了那种面对面访谈。你知道吗？她对着镜头说：“我以前约会过住着糟糕公寓的男人。我不能仅凭这一点评判他。我必须……我必须找出他为什么觉得他能住在这样的公寓里。”
She ditched him because of the apartment?
她因为公寓把他甩了？
Yeah. Yeah.
是的。没错。
Wait. He lost out on the bachelorette because of the apartment?
等等。他因为公寓而失去了单身女郎的青睐？
Oh yeah.
噢，是的。
And it was your apartment?
而且那还是你的公寓？
But better.
但更好。
[laughing]
（大笑）
Over the next few days it all sort of goes to hell for Jorge. He's depressed. His new life does not seem so shiny. His New York friends console him. Look, they say, the bachelorette had never seen a New York apartment before. She does not know how people here live. This means nothing. Which helps him for a while, until one day Jorge picks up the New York Post, and right there is an article about his neighbor, Todtman-- the guy from The Bachelorette-- getting busted for cocaine.
接下来的几天里，豪尔赫的生活简直陷入了地狱。他很沮丧。他的新生活看起来并不那么光鲜。他在纽约的朋友安慰他。看，他们说，那个单身女郎以前从没见过纽约公寓。她不知道这里的人是怎么生活的。这根本不算什么。这让他好受了一些，直到有一天，豪尔赫拿起《纽约邮报》，上面赫然有一篇关于他邻居托特曼（Todtman）——那个上《单身女郎》的家伙——因为可卡因被捕的报道。
Third paragraph. "Todtman's fate on The Bachelorette was sealed the moment Rehn set foot in his squalid Avenue A studio apartment."
第三段写道：“托特曼在《单身女郎》中的命运，从雷恩踏入他位于A大道那间破败不堪的一室公寓的那一刻起，就已经注定了。”
[laughing]
（大笑）
Do you understand the weight of that? Squalid. "Squalid Avenue A studio apartment."
你明白那分量吗？破败不堪（squalid）。“破败不堪的A大道一室公寓。”
So this isn't just like people from outside New York.
所以这不仅仅是外地人对纽约的看法。
This is the New York Post. Nobody knows New York apartments like the New York Post. These guys have been in the most squalid New York City apartments. It's squalid, you know? It's squalid. Squalid. Squalid. You know? There's not that many definitions for squalid. There's not many ways to look at the word squalid and think, mmm, maybe they mean kind of hip. You know?
这是《纽约邮报》。没人比《纽约邮报》更了解纽约的公寓了。这些人见过纽约市最破败的公寓。这很破败，你知道吗？真的很破败。破败、破败。你知道吗？“破败”这个词没有多少别的定义。你没法看着“破败”这个词想，“嗯，也许他们是指那种时髦的风格”。你知道吗？
Somehow, without ever meaning to, Jorge had the experience that a person would have if he actually went onto one of the reality shows, and then got booted off the show. National television came into his apartment, and then kicked him off the island, by proxy. He was like collateral damage to a reality show.
不知怎么地，豪尔赫在完全无意的情况下，体验到了那种真正参加真人秀节目然后被踢出局的人会有的经历。全国电视网进了他的公寓，然后代理性地把他从岛上踢走了。他就像真人秀节目的附带损害。
You know, I never-- I didn't want to be-- I didn't want America to judge me and tell me my apartment sucked, you know? I didn't want that. But that moment when they came into my building, and they opened that door, and it was my apartment, I thought I was-- you know-- I thought that I was hot. I thought that it was-- you know.
你知道，我从没……我不想……我不想让美国人评判我，告诉我我的公寓烂透了，你懂吗？我不想要那样。但当他们走进我的大楼，打开那扇门，发现那是我的公寓时，我以为我是……你知道……我以为我很时髦。我以为那是……你知道。
Yeah.
是啊。
And then all of a sudden it's like-- byoo byoo boo. [Ira laughs] You know?
然后突然间就像是……嘟嘟嘟。（艾拉笑）你懂吗？
What was it?
那是什么意思？
Byoo, byoo, byoo, byoo, byoo. You lose, you lose, you lose, you lose. You know?
嘟、嘟、嘟、嘟、嘟。你输了，你输了，你输了，你输了。你懂吗？
Jorge says that if he hadn't just moved to New York City, if he hadn't just started this whole life, it would not have been the kick in the stomach that it was, which brings us to today's radio program. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today on our show, starting from scratch. Stories of people in that period of their lives when everything is up for grabs. They're starting over. Everything is tenuous.
豪尔赫说，如果他不是刚搬到纽约，如果他不是刚刚开始这段全新的生活，这对他来说就不会是当头一棒。这引出了我们今天的广播节目。这里是来自芝加哥WBEZ的《美国生活》（This American Life）。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。今天我们的节目主题是“从零开始”。讲述那些生活在一切皆有可能的阶段的人们的故事。他们正在重新开始。一切都是脆弱的。
Act One, Puppy Love, the Business Model. Act Two. Making Money the Old-Fashioned Way. In that act, the story of a man-- a limo driver, in fact-- who begins each day from scratch with just a few bucks, and builds it to hundreds, thousands, or tens of thousands by the end of the day. Act Three. The First Starting From Scratch. In that act, Jonathan Goldstein revisits a possibly familiar tale of a man, a woman, a garden, and a snake. Stay with us.
第一幕，小狗之恋，商业模式。第二幕，以老式方式赚钱。在这一幕中，讲述了一个男人——实际上是一名豪华轿车司机——他每天都以仅仅几块钱从头开始，到一天结束时积累到数百、数千甚至数万美元。第三幕，第一次从零开始。在这一幕中，乔纳森·戈德斯坦（Jonathan Goldstein）重温了一个可能大家都很熟悉的故事：一个男人、一个女人、一个花园和一条蛇。请继续收听。
Act One. Puppy Love, the Business Model. OK. You know there are mom and pop grocery stores, mom and pop newspapers. But could you throw everything away, change your life, start your life over, and create a mom and pop cable network? Molly FitzSimons' own father tried. And she has the answer.
第一幕。小狗之恋，商业模式。好吧。你知道有家族经营的杂货店，有家族经营的报社。但你能否抛弃一切，改变生活，从头再来，创立一家家族经营的电视网？莫莉·菲茨西蒙斯（Molly FitzSimons）的父亲尝试过。而她有答案。
Some people's fathers quit their jobs and become teachers. Some maybe retire early and start a new hobby, like model building. My father, after turning over the reins of the business he'd owned and operated for 25 years, started a cable channel. From scratch.
有些人的父亲辞职当了老师。有些人可能提前退休，培养了一个新爱好，比如模型制作。我的父亲，在他经营了25年的生意交棒之后，创办了一个有线电视频道。从零开始。
It was February 1995, and he was looking for something new to do, but he didn't know what. Then came the O.J. trial. He had just had back surgery, and the day they sent him home for bedrest happened to be the day that the trial began. During the long breaks in the action he would flip through the channels.
那是1995年2月，他正在寻找新事情做，但他不知道该做什么。接着辛普森案（O.J. trial）开始了。他刚做了背部手术，他们让他回家卧床休息的那一天，恰好就是审判开始的日子。在漫长的庭审休庭期间，他会翻看各个频道。
There was so much downtime in the trial I had a chance to see everything that was on television all day long for weeks.
审判中有太多的停顿，我有机会在数周的时间里，一整天观察电视上播出的所有内容。
You mean you just surfed around while--
你的意思是你只是在……到处冲浪？
The slow points of the trial were most of the day. And I spent the time surfing around daytime television and seeing what it was.
审判的缓慢期占据了大部分时间。我花时间在日间电视节目里冲浪，看看那到底是什么。
What it was was mostly soap operas, talk shows, reruns, game shows. Things that my father had no interest in. My father is a problem solver, and this was a problem.
那其实大部分都是肥皂剧、脱口秀、重播和游戏节目。这些是我父亲毫无兴趣的东西。我父亲是个解决问题的人，而这正是一个问题。
So I thought, something else is necessary. There's a need for a parking place on television. If you don't want to watch something that is there you could have the TV set on, and it'd be playing something that didn't bother you, and would hold the place until your favorite show or what you chose to watch.
所以我认为，需要别的东西。电视上需要一个“停车位”。如果你不想看那上面播的东西，你可以开着电视，它播放一些不会打扰你的内容，为你喜爱的节目或你选择观看的内容占据那个位置。
For my father, like for a lot of people, simply turning off the television isn't an option. So he's stuck flipping through a bunch of shows that he hates waiting for the O.J. trial to come back on, when a little light bulb goes off in his head.
对我父亲来说，像许多人一样，简单地关掉电视并不是一个选择。所以他只能无奈地翻看着一堆他讨厌的节目，等待辛普森案恢复直播，这时他脑子里闪过一个灵感。
I recalled my wife and I walking to lunch on a Friday in downtown Cleveland, walking into a building where the Animal Protective League had puppies up for adoption. And the crowd of people standing around these puppies included men in three-piece suits, and women in fancy outfits, and shoppers, moms with kids in strollers, the UPS man.
我回忆起我和妻子在克利夫兰市中心走去吃午饭的一个周五，走进了一栋大楼，动物保护联盟在那儿有小狗待领养。围在这些小狗周围的人群里，有穿着三件套西装的男人，穿着精致套装的女人，购物者，推着婴儿车的妈妈，还有UPS快递员。
And they stood together smiling and chuckling, and even sometimes addressing one another in the middle of a big city building, all because there were puppies. The puppies made them feel better. And so my thought jumped to if television needs some other kind of programming, what would be wrong with one channel, out of the hundreds that there are, that showed nothing but puppies. All day, all night, every day.
他们站在一起微笑、轻笑，甚至有时在繁忙的城市大楼里互相交谈，这一切都是因为有小狗。小狗让他们感觉更好。所以我的思绪跳转到：如果电视需要另一种节目，那么在数百个频道中，有一个频道只播小狗又有什么不好呢？整天、整夜、每天。
The initial idea was all puppies all the time. You would turn to the Puppy Channel and you would see-- 24 hours a day, seven days a week-- footage of puppies fooling around like puppies do, acting the natural comedians and cuties that they are. With no people, no talk, accompanied only by relaxing instrumental music-- would be the Puppy Channel concept.
最初的想法是：全是小狗，永远是小狗。你转到“小狗频道”，你会看到——24小时，一周七天——小狗像小狗一样玩耍的镜头，展现它们天生的喜剧天赋和可爱。没有人类，没有对话，只有令人放松的器乐伴奏——这就是“小狗频道”的概念。
What are you looking for here?
你在找什么？
I'm looking for Ted Turner's letter, where he very nicely refused me in writing this time.
我在找泰德·特纳（Ted Turner）的信，这次他很客气地书面拒绝了我。
My father's home office in Clearwater, Florida, is all decked out with family photos, artifacts from his years in the ad business. And an entire wall of file cabinets, which has the complete Puppy Channel archive.
我父亲在佛罗里达州克利尔沃特市的家庭办公室里，摆满了家庭照片和他在广告界工作多年来的纪念品。还有整整一面墙的文件柜，里面存有完整的“小狗频道”档案。
What's that?
那是什么？
This is a demo that is on the way to being the pilot show.
这是正在制作中的试播节目样片。
He shows me a banker's box filled with videotapes, and pulls out the one-hour pilot he made early on in the Puppy Channel development. It's professionally packaged. There's a closeup of a puppy on the cover with the word "Woof." And two exclamation points.
他给我看了一个装满录像带的纸箱，拿出他早期制作的一小时试播集。包装非常专业。封面上有一张小狗的特写，写着“汪！”（Woof），还有两个感叹号。
OK. So it's a really-- it's a cute cover. Let's put it in. When's the last time you watched this?
好吧。这是一个非常……非常可爱的封面。我们放进去看看。你上一次看这个是什么时候？
I think it's been years since I watched this. [singing on video] Puppies, puppies, puppies, puppies, puppies, puppies, puppies, puppies, puppies. Puppies, puppies, puppies, puppies, puppies, puppies, puppies, puppies, puppies.
我想我已经好几年没看这个了。（录像中唱歌）小狗，小狗，小狗，小狗……小狗，小狗，小狗，小狗……
You may recognize this voice. It's my dad. He also wrote the lyrics.
你可能认出这个声音。是我爸爸。歌词也是他写的。
Puppies, puppies, puppies, puppies, puppies, puppies, puppies, puppies, puppies, puppies, puppies, puppies. Puppies, puppies, puppies, puppies, puppies, puppies, puppies, puppies, puppies. Puppies! [puppies bark in the background]
小狗，小狗，小狗……小狗，小狗，小狗……（背景里有狗叫声）
The scene fades up to a family of old English sheepdog puppies playing and barking in a wood-paneled suburban den somewhere, with mellow guitar music in the background. After a couple of minutes the scene changes to a corgi puppy running in circles on a snow-covered lawn. Soon border collies are fighting over a sock on somebody's linoleum kitchen floor. It's exactly what you'd expect from my dad's description of the Puppy Channel.
场景淡入，一群英国老式牧羊犬小狗在木镶板的郊区书房里玩耍、叫唤，背景是悠扬的吉他音乐。几分钟后，场景切换到一只柯基幼犬在积雪覆盖的草坪上转圈跑。很快，边境牧羊犬为了某人的油毡厨房地板上的一只袜子打架。这完全是你从我爸爸对“小狗频道”的描述中预期的样子。
And what's so surprising is that it really is nothing more than that. Throughout the hour-long pilot, puppies waddle around and sniff things. Puppies wrestle and nuzzle each other adorably. It's a soft focus world of indescribable cuteness. Occasionally, my dad's singing interrupts the relaxing instrumental soundtrack.
最令人惊讶的是，它真的不过如此。在一小时的试播节目中，小狗蹒跚走动，嗅着各种东西。小狗摔跤、亲昵，可爱至极。这是一个充满难以言喻的可爱感、柔焦的世界。偶尔，我爸爸的歌声会打断放松的纯音乐配乐。
Wait. This is your voice, right?
等等。这是你的声音，对吧？
[singing] Puppies are everywhere. Puppies go anywhere. Watch the Puppy Channel now for puppies on TV.
（唱歌）小狗无处不在。小狗随处可见。现在就看小狗频道，电视里全是小狗。
That's like the, um, theme song?
这是……嗯，主题曲？
That's the third Puppy Channel theme.
这是“小狗频道”的第三首主题曲。
Aww. Look at that one, with the big ears flopping up in the air.
噢。看那只，大耳朵在空中扑腾。
At some point while we're watching, my dad's wife, Carol-- who's been listening quietly to our conversation from the other side of the room-- comes over and starts cooing at the television. Carol went with my father on most of the Puppy Channel shoots, and actually had the idea for what became the big climactic final scene of the pilot.
在我们观看的时候，我爸爸的妻子卡罗尔（Carol）——她一直在房间另一头静静地听我们的谈话——走了过来，开始对着电视发出赞叹。卡罗尔几乎陪我父亲参加了“小狗频道”所有的拍摄，而且她其实想出了后来成为试播节目最高潮结尾场景的点子。
Here's a scene of all 10 of the dogs on a sofa, and how they get off. Some of them are vigorous in getting off. Some of them are a little reluctant.
这是一个所有10只狗都在沙发上的场景，看它们怎么下来。有些下来时很有活力。有些则有点不情愿。
This was your idea, Carol?
这是你的主意吗，卡罗尔？
I thought it would be cute.
我觉得这样会很可爱。
It's not just cute. It's also suspenseful. Most of the puppies immediately jump or tumble off the couch onto the carpeted floor. But a couple of them stay up there looking sort of confused. It's a pretty long sequence. I glance around the room during it, and realize that all of us are smiling. And we're watching with rapt attention to see if the two cowardly puppies will ever find their way down off the couch. One of the two finally does, leaving only one puppy left. And to give you an idea of the drama of the moment, let me put it this way. We all find ourselves talking to the TV.
这不仅可爱，而且充满悬念。大多数小狗立即跳下或滚下沙发，落到铺着地毯的地板上。但有两只留在上面，看起来有点困惑。这是一个相当长的片段。我在看的时候环顾四周，发现我们都在微笑。我们全神贯注地看着那两只胆小的小狗是否能找到下沙发的方法。其中一只终于做到了，只剩最后一只。为了让你感受那刻的戏剧性，我这么说吧，我们所有人都发现自己在对着电视说话。
Come on.
加油。
Come on. You can do it.
加油。你可以做到的。
You can do it. Come on. No. Wrong way.
你可以做到的。加油。不。方向错了。
Finally, after a good three or four minutes, the last puppy sort of half jumps, half falls off the couch. And all of us cheer.
终于，在大约三四分钟后，最后一只小狗半跳半跌下了沙发。我们所有人都欢呼起来。
The moment. Yes. Success.
就是这一刻。耶。成功了。
Nice move into slow-mo there.
那个慢动作切换得不错。
The whole time my dad was doing the Puppy Channel, I could never decide if I thought the idea was genius or totally insane. And the thing that made it seem super smart was the same thing that made it seem kind of crazy-- namely, puppies. Suddenly my businessman dad was talking so much and so fervently about puppies it was kind of weird. And my question was always how would the Puppy Channel possibly make any money.
在我爸爸做“小狗频道”的整个过程中，我从来没决定好我到底是认为这个想法是天才还是完全疯了。而让它看起来超聪明的东西，恰恰也是让它看起来有点疯狂的原因——也就是，小狗。突然间，我那个商人爸爸谈论小狗谈得那么多、那么热切，这让人觉得有点怪。而我一直以来的疑问是：小狗频道到底怎么赚钱？
When I asked my father this question, he was so convincing that I started to wonder why it's not on television right now. Here's how it would work. There'd be fees from cable operators, and there'd be product placements and sponsorships. You'd see a bunch of puppies tearing into a bag of puppy chow, for example. Or a scroll across the bottom of the screen saying, this hour of the Puppy Channel brought to you by Milk Bone. In focus groups it did well-- 37% preferred it to TBS. 41% to CNBC. And remember, my dad didn't need a huge audience to succeed.
当我问我父亲这个问题时，他的解释非常有说服力，以至于我开始怀疑为什么现在电视上没有这个节目。它是这样运作的：会有来自有线电视运营商的费用，还会有产品植入和赞助。例如，你会看到一群小狗撕开一袋狗粮。或者屏幕底部滚动播放字幕，写着“本小时小狗频道由Milk Bone赞助播出”。在焦点小组测试中，它表现很好——37%的人更喜欢它而不是TBS。41%的人喜欢它胜过CNBC。记住，我爸爸不需要庞大的观众群就能成功。
At the time we created the Puppy Channel, television channels with the tiniest little sliver of audience were worth hundreds of millions of dollars. Court Television sold one third of its stock for $100 million, which presumably means the thing was worth $300 million. And their primetime ratings was 1/10 of 1% of the TV audience at that time. Based on our research, that even though the Puppy Channel would appeal to a very small segment of people, that segment would be big enough to make it a success.
在我们创建“小狗频道”的时候，那些只有极小部分观众的电视频道价值数亿美元。Court Television以1亿美元卖出了三分之一的股票，这大概意味着它价值3亿美元。而它们当时在黄金时段的收视率只有电视观众总数的千分之一。根据我们的研究，虽然“小狗频道”只吸引很小一部分人，但那部分人群已经足够让它成功。
But even a small cable channel was a huge venture compared to anything my father had done before. By his reckoning, he needed to raise $17 million to get on the air. Or he needed a big cable company to buy his idea.
但即便是一个小型的有线频道，与我父亲之前做过的任何事情相比，都是一项巨大的冒险。按照他的计算，他需要筹集1700万美元才能开播。或者他需要一家大型有线电视公司买下他的想法。
And so he and Carol started hustling. And after 25 years of being at the center of their own small familiar world, they suddenly found themselves in middle age, on the fringes of a much larger and stranger one. There were cable conventions.
于是他和卡罗尔开始四处奔波。在他们自己那个熟悉的小世界中心度过了25年后，他们突然发现自己人到中年，处于一个更大、更陌生的世界的边缘。他们参加了有线电视大会。
We had a little tiny booth way in the corner. And we had a million people coming around wanting to get our video.
我们在角落里有一个很小很小的展位。有上百万人过来想要我们的录像带。
And what was your role there?
那你当时的角色是什么？
Um, dog. [both laughing]
嗯，狗。（两人大笑）
What?
什么？
I dressed as a dog. And I painted my nose black. Yeah. And couldn't get the black out of the pores of my nose for days.
我打扮成了一只狗。我把鼻子涂黑了。是的。好几天都洗不掉鼻子毛孔里的黑色素。
Whose idea was it for you to wear a dog suit?
让你穿狗装是谁的主意？
I think it was-- I think it was your father's. Of course it was your father's. Would I have voluntarily done that? These are the things you do for love. [laughing]
我想是……我想是你父亲的。当然是你父亲的。我会自愿做那种事吗？这些都是为了爱而做的事情。（大笑）
Fortune magazine published a photo of Carol in her dog suit. The media loved the Puppy Channel. There was an article about it on the cover of the Hollywood Reporter. There were favorable blurbs in Entertainment Weekly and USA Today. Everybody loved it. Everybody except the ones who, at this stage, mattered most. People like Ted Turner, Barry Diller, and Rupert Murdoch all got the Puppy Channel pitch. But my father couldn't make the sale.
《财富》杂志刊登了一张卡罗尔穿着狗装的照片。媒体非常喜欢“小狗频道”。《好莱坞报道》的封面上有一篇关于它的文章。《娱乐周刊》和《今日美国》也有好评。《娱乐周刊》和《今日美国》都发了积极的短文。每个人都喜欢它。除了在这个阶段最重要的人。泰德·特纳、巴里·迪勒（Barry Diller）和鲁珀特·默多克（Rupert Murdoch）等人都听过“小狗频道”的推介。但我父亲没能卖出去。
One of the TV professionals that we talked to was talking about the amount of space on a satellite-- they call it bandwidth today-- that it takes to have a commercial TV network shown. He said something like, you'd ask us to give up six megaschlocks of gooberschnapp to put just puppies on there? And the answer is yes. But if you are the guy who owns the six megagoops of schlockendock, you're maybe not gonna give it up for puppies.
我们交谈过的电视专业人士中，有一位谈到了卫星上的空间量——他们今天称之为带宽——展示一个商业电视网络所需要的资源。他说了类似这样的话：“你让我们放弃六兆赫的传输带宽，就为了放一堆小狗？”而答案是肯定的。但如果你是那个拥有六兆赫带宽的人，你可能不会为了小狗放弃它。
But why? He doesn't like puppies? Or--
但为什么？他不喜欢小狗吗？还是……
No. It's a foreign concept to want to go way far off the beaten path. The Puppy Channel is way off the beaten path. It has no people. It has no talk.
不。想要走远路偏离常规是一个陌生的概念。“小狗频道”就是完全偏离常规。它没有人类，没有对话。
Usually when you describe this, you do mention that there would be no talk, and that seems to be a big part of what you liked about the idea. Why do you think that is? Why were you so interested in a channel where nobody talked?
通常当你描述这个时，你会提到没有对话，这似乎是你喜欢这个想法的一大部分原因。你认为为什么会这样？为什么你对一个没人说话的频道如此感兴趣？
Having a human being in the picture talking about what the puppies were doing, or talking about something, struck me as against the concept originally of just having a quiet place on television that was all relaxing, all comfort, all easy and pleasure-giving in a very, very low-key way.
屏幕里有人在谈论小狗在做什么，或者谈论别的东西，这在最初就让我觉得违背了这个概念，即在电视上拥有一个安静的空间，完全放松、舒适，以非常非常低调的方式带来享受和愉悦。
One person my father talked to characterized the Puppy Channel as the antidote to television. And in the end, I think that's probably why it never worked out. My dad hadn't just imagined a new cable network. He'd imagined a new way to think about what television can be.
我父亲谈过的一位人士将“小狗频道”描述为电视的“解毒剂”。最终，我想这就是它行不通的原因。我爸爸不仅构想了一个新的有线电视网。他构想了一种思考电视可以是什么的新方式。
What you'd get from watching the Puppy Channel would be very different than what you get watching the Food Network or QVC. Or Law and Order, for that matter. In his business plan, along with all the spreadsheets and financial outlines, under the section titled "Vision," it says only "to make television more helpful." And under "Mission," "to help people relax and feel better."
观看“小狗频道”所获得的感觉，与观看“美食频道”（Food Network）或QVC截然不同。或者说Law and Order。在他的商业计划书中，所有的电子表格和财务大纲旁边，在题为“愿景”的部分，只写着“让电视更有帮助”。而在“使命”部分写着，“帮助人们放松，感觉更好”。
My father conceived of the Puppy Channel as a refuge from regular TV. But implicit in this notion is the idea that regular TV is something you need a refuge from. And that's a tough sell to the people who make it. After five years of hard work, my father decided to pull the plug. I'm just going to put it out there and say I think the world wasn't ready for the Puppy Channel.
我父亲将“小狗频道”设想为普通电视的避难所。但这个概念隐含着这样一个想法：普通电视是你需要避难的地方。对于制造它的人来说，这很难推销。经过五年的努力，我父亲决定放弃了。我想坦诚地说，我认为世界还没准备好迎接“小狗频道”。
If there were 1,000 television channels, the Puppy Channel might be in there. If there were 600 television channels regularly being sent out by the satellites, the Puppy Channel might be there. There's a number where the puppy generally fits in. We just don't know what that number is.
如果有1000个电视频道，“小狗频道”可能就在其中。如果有600个通过卫星常规传输的电视频道，“小狗频道”可能就在那里。一定有一个数字，小狗通常能适应。我们只是不知道那个数字是多少。
When we find out what that number is I'll be there with my dad. And we'll be singing this song. Take us out, Dad.
当我们发现那个数字是多少时，我会和我爸爸在那里。我们会唱这首歌。开始吧，爸爸。
[singing] I love the little puppies, pretty little puppies. I love the little puppies on the Puppy Channel, every little pup on TV.
（唱歌）我爱小狗狗，漂亮的小狗狗。我爱小狗频道里的小狗狗，电视上每一只小狗。
Molly FitzSimons and her dad.
莫莉·菲茨西蒙斯和她的父亲。
Since we first broadcast this story back in 2003 we have obviously seen the incredible demand for cute puppy videos on YouTube. There's the Puppy Bowl on Animal Planet. There is Dog TV, a channel intended to be watched by dogs. Molly's dad, Dan FitzSimons, died in 2016, but obviously was far ahead of his time. Molly says that he delighted in the fact that his idea, a cozy corner of the world for watching puppies, caught in the act of being cute, flourished in all these other forms.
自从我们在2003年首次播出这个故事以来，我们显然看到了YouTube上对可爱小狗视频的惊人需求。动物星球频道有“小狗碗”（Puppy Bowl）。有一个频道叫“狗狗电视”（Dog TV），是专门给狗看的。莫莉的父亲丹·菲茨西蒙斯于2016年去世，但他显然远远超前于时代。莫莉说，他很高兴他的想法——一个观看小狗被捕捉到可爱瞬间的舒适角落——在所有这些其他形式中蓬勃发展。
[MUSIC - "NOTHING FROM NOTHING BY BILLY PRESTON]
（音乐 - 比利·普雷斯顿的《Nothing from Nothing》）
Nothing from nothing leaves nothing. You gotta have something if you wanna be with me. Nothing from nothing leaves nothing. You gotta have something if you're gonna be with me.
Nothing from nothing leaves nothing. You gotta have something if you wanna be with me.（空手难成事，若想与我同行，你得有所作为。）
Act two. Making money the old-fashioned way. Well, now we bring you the story of someone who starts from scratch every single day with next to nothing, and tries to build it up to something. Mary Beth Kirchner tells the story.
第二幕。以老式方式赚钱。好吧，现在我们要带你讲述一个每天从零开始，几乎一无所有，并试图将其积累成某样东西的人的故事。玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔（Mary Beth Kirchner）讲述了这个故事。
(HOST) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: Every day Joe plays this game. He starts with enough small bills to make change-- lots of fives and ones-- then the clock starts. It's 1:30 in the morning.
（主持人）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：每一天，乔都在玩这个游戏。他从足够找零的小额钞票开始——大量的五块钱和一块钱——然后钟表开始走动。现在是凌晨1:30。
I go out with almost nothing in my pocket in the morning. And sometimes I end up with thousands. Sometimes I end up broke at the end of the day.
我早上出门时口袋里几乎什么都没有。有时一天结束时我会有几千块。有时一天结束时我会破产。
(INTERVIEWER) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: So how much do you have in your pocket today?
（采访者）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：那你今天口袋里有多少钱？
I got $32 in my pocket today. By six o'clock I should have at least a couple hundred bucks. And you know, I take it from there.
我今天口袋里有32块。到六点钟我至少应该有几百块。你知道，我从那开始。
(HOST) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: By 6:00 AM, he means. Joe, who doesn't want me to use his last name, drives a super stretch limousine in Las Vegas. Joe says he prefers starting in the middle of the night. Doesn't like crowds or traffic. Here's how his game works. By driving his limo to and from the airport mostly, Joe slowly earns enough-- a few hundred dollars-- to play blackjack in the casino. And then pretty much the sky's the limit.
（主持人）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：他指的6:00 AM。乔，他不希望我用他的姓，在拉斯维加斯开一辆超级加长豪华轿车。乔说他更喜欢在半夜开始。不喜欢拥挤和交通。他的游戏运作方式是这样的：乔主要驾驶他的豪华轿车往返于机场，慢慢赚够钱——几百美元——然后去赌场玩二十一点。在那之后，基本上一切皆有可能。
Sometimes I end up with 10 grand, you know? One time I started out with like 32 bucks or $33--
有时我最终会有一万块，你知道吗？有一次我从32块或33块开始——
(INTERVIEWER) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: Like today.
（采访者）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：就像今天一样。
Like today. And I wound up with $84,000 at the Gold Coast.
就像今天一样。最后我在黄金海岸（Gold Coast）赢了84,000美元。
(INTERVIEWER) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: $84,000?
（采访者）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：84,000美元？
$84,000.
84,000美元。
(INTERVIEWER) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: How do you turn 32--
（采访者）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：你怎么把32……
I try and build it up to like $1,000, then I play with the $1,000. I build it up to three, four, and then you get on a run.
我试着把它积累到1000美元左右，然后我用1000美元玩。我把它积累到三千、四千，然后你就会开始连赢。
(HOST) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: Joe is a bit of a legend in Las Vegas gambling circles. I'd heard about him from a pawnbroker south of the strip who said Joe was a regular customer who came every month for about a year. Among the stories he told me, which led me to Joe, that he'd never worked a day in his life. That he lived only on a trust fund until he was 50, controlled by his father who despised his love of gambling.
（主持人）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：乔在拉斯维加斯的赌博圈子里算是个传奇人物。我是从大道南边的一个典当商那里听说他的，他说乔是个常客，大约一年来每个月都来。在他告诉我的故事中（这些故事引出了乔），他说他这辈子从来没上过班。直到50岁之前，他一直靠信托基金生活，由他那鄙视他赌博爱好的父亲控制。
On his 50th birthday, the legend went, Joe inherited six million. He instantly spent the first million on a house. The remaining five he gambled away. It took him five hours. Joe says not true, but based on the truth. He did inherit millions of dollars from his family, and did lose a big piece of it gambling. But over years. Not hours.
传说在他50岁生日那天，乔继承了600万。他立刻花掉前100万买了一栋房子。剩下的500万他全拿去赌博了。花了五个小时。乔说这不是真的，但基于事实。他确实从家里继承了数百万美元，也确实在赌博中输掉了其中的很大一部分。但那是经过多年。不是几小时。
People tell me, oh, look at the kind of life you lead. I mean, one day I could have a million dollars. The next day I'd be broke. But I love it. I love the action. I love the adrenaline. I get an adrenaline rush from it.
人们告诉我，哦，看看你过的那种生活。我的意思是，有一天我可以拥有一百万美元。第二天我就可能破产。但我喜欢。我喜欢那种行动。我喜欢那种肾上腺素。我从中获得肾上腺素飙升的快感。
(INTERVIEWER) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: One day you have a million dollars and the next day you're broke? Is that an exaggeration, or really--
（采访者）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：有一天你有一百万美元，第二天你就破产了？这是夸张，还是真的——
No. It's not an exaggeration. I mean, I had days where I went in and I won-- like at the horseshoe I won $680,000. I started the day out with like 50 bucks in my pocket. And I went out and I bought two homes with some of the money. Then I ended up losing the other money. Then I needed money so I borrowed on the houses. And then I lost the houses. I couldn't pay.
不。这不夸张。我的意思是，有几天我进去赢了——比如在马蹄铁（Horseshoe）我赢了68万美元。我那天早上口袋里只有50块钱左右。然后我出去用其中的一些钱买了两套房子。后来我输掉了剩下的钱。接着我需要钱，所以我抵押了房子。后来我输掉了房子。我付不起钱。
I go up and down. It's like a roller coaster. But I really enjoy doing it. You know? I think without it I'll just wilt away and die. See, this is one of the hotels. The Barbary Coast won't let me in. If I go in there and sit down for two minutes they'll tell me to get up and leave.
我起起伏伏。就像坐过山车。但我真的很享受。你懂吗？我觉得如果没有它，我只会枯萎死亡。看，这就是其中一家酒店。巴巴里海岸（Barbary Coast）不让我进去。如果我进去坐两分钟，他们会叫我起身离开。
(HOST) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: Joe has a long history of winning big at the casinos. So much so, and this is clearly true, about a dozen of them in Las Vegas have kicked him out. He says most of them think he cheats. Nobody could be that lucky, they say. Among the places where he's still allowed to play, none wanted their names mentioned, or would allow me to record in their casinos today. So we were limited to taping outdoors, where most of Joe's game happens anyway.
（主持人）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：乔在赌场赢大钱的记录很长。以至于——这显然是真的——拉斯维加斯大约有十几家赌场把他赶了出去。他说他们大多数人认为他出老千。他们说，没人能那么幸运。在他仍然被允许玩的地方，没有一家想提到他们的名字，也不允许我在今天的赌场里录音。所以我们只能在户外录音，反正乔的大部分游戏也是在那里进行的。
Sometimes you'll stand here for like half hour and nobody will come out. But as soon as they come out to take a cab I approach them.
有时你在这里站上半小时，没人会出来。但只要他们出来打车，我就接近他们。
(HOST) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: First stop. His favorite nameless hotel and casino, where the doorman lets him approach potential customers from the circular driveway out front. Joe tips the doorman for each ride he gets, so he gives Joe first dibs on every person who walks out the door.
（主持人）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：第一站。他最喜欢的无名酒店和赌场，那里的门童允许他从外面的圆形车道接近潜在客户。乔给门童每单生意都付小费，所以门童让乔优先接待每一个走出门的客人。
You guys need a cab?
你们需要打车吗？
Yes.
是的。
How about this? 15 bucks.
这个怎么样？15块。
15 bucks?
15块？
(HOST) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: With the approval of the doorman, lots of people say yes.
（主持人）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：在门童的许可下，很多人会说好。
Isn't this a lot nicer than a cab?
这不比出租车好多了吗？
A lot nicer.
好多了。
See.
瞧。
(HOST) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: It's 2:00 AM, with our first $15 coming in. Joe says he started waking up at these hours when he worked in New York operating vending machines and coffee carts, gambling in Atlantic City on weekends. There, too, he says most of the casinos kicked him out.
（主持人）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：现在是凌晨2点，我们刚赚了第一笔15美元。乔说他是在纽约操作自动售货机和咖啡车，周末在亚特兰大城赌博时开始在这种时候起床的。在那里，他也说大多数赌场把他赶了出去。
By the time he came to Vegas 14 years ago, he says he was ready to retire, but he gambled full-time for the first eight years he was here.
14年前他来到拉斯维加斯时，他说他准备退休了，但他在这里的前八年是全职赌博。
Well, he's not a dishonest man by no means. But, you know, he is an opportunist. He's the type of guy if there's an opportunity for him to, you know, work the odds or make a dollar he'll make ten. He's one of them guys.
嗯，他绝对不是个不诚实的人。但是，你知道，他是个机会主义者。他属于那种只要有机会让他利用赔率或者赚一美元，他就会赚十美元的那种人。他是这类人中的一员。
(HOST) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: George-- please don't mention my full name, either, or where I work-- is a casino manager in one of the few places where Joe now plays. We met in an empty hotel ballroom, far from the casino floor.
（主持人）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：乔治——也请不要提我的全名，或者我在哪里工作——是乔现在玩的地方中，少数几家赌场的一位经理。我们在一家空的酒店宴会厅见面，离赌场区域很远。
They think he counts cards. He doesn't. He's very good at knowing when the deck goes cold-- when there's not a chance of winning. If I would own a casino and have 1,000 Joes walking around in my casino I'd be out of business in short order.
他们以为他在算牌。他没算。他非常擅长判断牌堆何时变冷——当没有获胜机会时。如果我拥有一个赌场，有1000个像乔这样的人在我的赌场里走来走去，我很快就会破产。
Well, maybe not. Joe walks away with his winnings, but then he always comes back for more play. And that combination, George says, does to Joe what it does to everyone.
好吧，也许不会。乔拿着赢来的钱走了，但他总是回来接着玩。乔治说，这种结合对乔造成了对每个人都会造成的结果。
I see the numbers. There's not a player in this place, like in any casino I've ever been in, that has won more than they lost.
我看过数据。在这个地方，就像我在任何赌场里见过的一样，没有一个玩家赢的钱超过输掉的钱。
Never?
从来没有吗？
I'd say never, when you see the cumulative numbers.
当我看到累计数字时，我会说从来没有。
And that's one reason why Joe is driving a limo.
这就是乔开车的原因之一。
If these guys are going to a strip club that would be great. That's $100.
如果这些人要去脱衣舞俱乐部那太好了。那是100块。
(HOST) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: 5:00 AM, and we've got $180.
（主持人）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：凌晨5点，我们赚了180块。
Where are you guys going to?
你们要去哪儿？
(HOST) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: Joe has his eye on a group of guys who've clearly been out on the town for most of the night.
（主持人）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：乔盯上了一群显然在城里玩了大半晚上的家伙。
Whoo!
喔！
(HOST) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: Joe's hoping these four are looking to go to a strip club, because he gets a kickback of $20 a person.
（主持人）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：乔希望这四个人想去脱衣舞俱乐部，因为他能拿到每人20美元的回扣。
Are you guys having fun?
你们玩得开心吗？
We planned it. Turn the radio up.
我们计划好的。把收音机调大。
You want the radio on? Radio is optional. It's more money. I got anything you want, as long as you got money.
你们想听广播吗？广播是可选的。那是更多的钱。只要你有钱，我什么都能提供。
(HOST) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: Joe tells me he also takes guys to the brothels a half hour drive from Las Vegas, and collects even more. [men singing]
（主持人）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：乔告诉我他还会带人去离拉斯维加斯半小时车程的妓院，赚的更多。（男人们唱歌）
We take people out there and we usually get 30. Now for the holidays they're doing 40% of what the person spends. If a person spends $1,000 we get $400 kickback for bringing them out there.
我们带人去那里，通常我们拿30%。现在为了过节，他们给出顾客消费额的40%。如果一个人花了1000美元，我们带他们去就能得到400美元的回扣。
(HOST) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: Now, what do you mean, "for the holidays?"
（主持人）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：那么，你说的“为了过节”是什么意思？
Till December. They're doing like a special. Instead of 30% they're giving us another 10%. Because I have pictures of everything in my trunk. I have a menu also. They have a menu of all the stuff you could do.
直到十二月。他们正在做促销活动。而不是30%，他们多给我们10%。因为我的后备箱里有所有东西的照片。我还有一份菜单。他们有一份菜单，列出了所有你可以做的活动。
Yeah, I love Vegas!
是的，我爱拉斯维加斯！
(HOST) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: As we drive, the stories keep coming. There was the day Joe won big at the race track and flew to London on the Concorde just for dinner. Or the two-day stretch he was playing $20,000 a hand at the Hilton, and walked away with over a million dollars. These kinds of stories can't be confirmed, but I wanted to believe them. So he offered to show me what's in his trunk.
（主持人）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：当我们开车时，故事不断。有一天，乔在赛马场赢了一大笔钱，飞往伦敦乘协和式飞机只是为了吃顿晚餐。或者是他连续两天在希尔顿以每手20,000美元的价格玩牌，最后带着超过一百万美元离开。这类故事无法确认，但我想要相信它们。所以他提出给我看他的后备箱里有什么。
See this? This is about a half a million dollars in markers right here.
看这个？这儿有大约50万美元的筹码兑换券。
(HOST) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: Joe hands me a three-inch stack of receipts from casinos all over town totaling about a half million dollars. Evidence, he says, he wants me to see that these can't all be lies.
（主持人）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：乔递给我一叠三英寸厚的收据，来自全城的赌场，总额约50万美元。他说，这是证明，他想让我看，这些不可能都是谎言。
(INTERVIEWER) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: And what are those 20,000?
（采访者）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：那20,000美元是什么？
Yeah. They loaned me $20,000 to sit and play with.
是的。他们借给我20,000美元让我坐下来玩。
(INTERVIEWER) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: Oh.
（采访者）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：噢。
You know? If you lose you've got 30 days to pay it back.
你知道吗？如果你输了，你有30天的时间偿还。
(INTERVIEWER) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: These are $20,000, $20,000.
（采访者）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：这些是20,000美元，20,000美元。
Yeah, they're all like--
是的，它们都是像——
(INTERVIEWER) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: $25,000.
（采访者）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：25,000美元。
Yeah.
是的。
(INTERVIEWER) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: And what's this?
（采访者）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：这是什么？
This is my uncle in Forbes magazine. He made like close to a billion dollars.
这是我叔叔在《福布斯》杂志上。他赚了接近十亿美元。
(INTERVIEWER) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: He's your uncle?
（采访者）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：他是你叔叔？
Yeah. That's my uncle.
是的。那是我叔叔。
(INTERVIEWER) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: Billionaire?
（采访者）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：亿万富翁？
Yeah.
是的。
(HOST) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: Later when I look into it that story checks out, as does the one about his aunt, who Joe says sits on the board of the Metropolitan Opera in New York. He says she's the one who bails him out when he gets over his head in debt. Joe admits he's the black sheep in the family.
（主持人）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：后来我调查了一下，那个故事是真实的，关于他阿姨的故事也是，乔说她坐在纽约大都会歌剧院的董事会上。他说当他债务缠身时，是她把他解救出来的。乔承认他是家里的黑羊。
(INTERVIEWER) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: How much did they give you?
（采访者）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：他们给了你多少钱？
$41.
41块。
(HOST) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: It's 7:30 AM and we're up to $350 from the run to the strip club, and five trips to the airport.
（主持人）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：现在是上午7:30，我们从去脱衣舞俱乐部的路上和五趟机场接送中赚了350美元。
And we just keep going around and around.
我们一直在绕来绕去。
(INTERVIEWER) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: There's a brief lull. Joe says it's time to go into the casino.
（采访者）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：有一个短暂的休息。乔说现在是进赌场的时候了。
I'm gonna go play a little blackjack. The only thing is I don't know if they're gonna let you--
我要去玩点二十一点。唯一的问题是我不知道他们会不会让你——
(HOST) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: Of course they're not.
（主持人）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：当然不会。
They won't.
他们不会。
(INTERVIEWER) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: The casino won't let me record his play, of course, but I watch.
（采访者）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：赌场当然不会让我录下他的玩法，但我可以看。
I'm going to play with $100 now. I'm making $50 or $60 in like 15 minutes, or less.
我现在要用100美元玩。我在15分钟或更短的时间内赚了50或60美元。
(HOST) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: Joe sits in front of a woman dealer with an empty table. And he's got that look, almost like a drinker who bellies up to a bar every night. Like he belongs there. He signals the woman for cards and chips in quick short-cut hand signals. Each hand takes less than a minute. He plays a few, and easily wins his $60 in 10 minutes or less. Before I know it we're out again. 8 AM with $410. He says it's getting to be peak time for airport runs.
（主持人）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：乔坐在一位女发牌员对面，桌上没人。他带着那种表情，几乎就像一个每天晚上都趴在吧台前的酒鬼。就像他属于那里一样。他用快速、简洁的手势向那个女人示意要牌和筹码。每手牌花不到一分钟。他玩了几手，在10分钟或更短时间内轻松赢了他的60美元。在我意识到之前我们又出来了。上午8点，有410美元。他说现在是去机场的高峰时间。
See now it gets busy, so I don't have a chance to get to really go in and gamble because I'm, you know-- As long as I keep the cash coming in. If it's slow I supplement it with gambling. If it's not I just, you know.
看，现在忙起来了，所以我没有机会真正进去赌博，因为我……只要我保持现金进账。如果不忙，我用赌博来补充。如果不忙我就……你知道。
(INTERVIEWER) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: But you wouldn't rather be gambling?
（采访者）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：但你不是更喜欢赌博吗？
I'd rather be working.
我更喜欢工作。
(INTERVIEWER) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: Really?
（采访者）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：真的吗？
Yeah.
是的。
(INTERVIEWER) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: What happened to your feeling about the gambling?
（采访者）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：你对赌博的感觉怎么了？
I just do it to, you know-- because I'm so hyper I have to have something to do. I used to sit-- like I was at the Flamingo one time, and I had about $40,000 in chips in front of me. And I was playing like $2,000 a hand. And I told the doorman if you get a good ride, like to a golf course, come and get me. So it was like a $75--
我这么做只是为了，你知道——因为我太兴奋了，我必须找点事情做。我以前坐过——有一次我在火烈鸟赌场，我面前有大约40,000美元的筹码。我在玩一手2000美元。我告诉门童，如果你得到一个好的单子，比如去高尔夫球场，来找我。大概是75美元——
Anyway, he came up to the table, and he told me I got a ride for $75. And people in the pit, they all think I'm nuts. I just stopped. I left, took my money, and I ran down to take a guy for $75. And here I am playing two grand a head. And I try and separate the two. One has nothing to do with the other, you know?
反正，他走到桌前，告诉我有一个75美元的单子。坑里的人，他们都认为我疯了。我就停了下来。我离开了，拿着我的钱，跑去载一个人挣75美元。而我当时每手牌玩两千。我试着把两者分开。一个与另一个无关，你知道吗？
(INTERVIEWER) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: I don't understand that.
（采访者）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：我不明白。
Nobody does. But that's how I am. You know?
没人明白。但我就是这样。你知道吗？
(INTERVIEWER) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: But do you understand that?
（采访者）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：那你明白吗？
Just gambling to me is gambling. Work is work. You know?
对我来说赌博就是赌博。工作就是工作。你知道吗？
(INTERVIEWER) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: 10:00 AM, and we've got $650. We've had three more airport runs, and the last customer just gave him a $25 tip.
（采访者）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：上午10点，我们有650美元。我们又接了三单机场生意，最后一个客户刚给了他25美元小费。
Only in America.
只有在美国才这样。
(INTERVIEWER) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: But Joe says today his game is subdued compared to the past. At age 54 he's had some heart trouble, and that's changed the stakes. A year ago his daughter was home from college, and noticed he didn't look well and called for an ambulance. Joe was having a heart attack.
（采访者）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：但乔说他今天的表现比起过去是比较克制的。54岁时，他有过一些心脏问题，这改变了筹码。一年前他的女儿从大学回家，注意到他看起来不太好，叫了救护车。乔心脏病发作了。
It was pretty scary just to see him in-- I think he might have been in a casino but I'm not there.
看到他在那种情况下确实很吓人——我想他可能在赌场里，但我当时不在那里。
(INTERVIEWER) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: I guess that's enough to really get your heart rate up.
（采访者）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：我想那足以让你的心率升高了。
Yeah. If you ask me, I think he probably was, but he never told me for sure.
是的。如果问我，我想他可能是在那里，但他从没确切告诉过我。
(HOST) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: Joe's daughter knew what she was doing. She's studying to be a doctor in medical school in the Middle East. I talked with her via her cell phone while she was working at a hospital in some remote spot in Israel. She asked that I not use her name. Not even her first name.
（主持人）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：乔的女儿知道她在做什么。她在中东的一所医学院学习成为一名医生。我在她工作时通过手机与她交谈，她在以色列的一个偏远地区的一家医院。她要求我不要用她的名字。连名字都不要用。
(INTERVIEWER) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: What did you tell your friends your dad did?
（采访者）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：你告诉朋友你爸爸做什么？
Now or when I was growing up? Because now even I don't-- only a few people in my class really know, of my good friends even.
现在还是我长大的时候？因为现在连我都不——即使是我的好朋友，班上也只有几个人真正知道。
(INTERVIEWER) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: What did you tell them then?
（采访者）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：那你当时告诉他们什么？
Then I would say, well, he's not really doing anything now, but he has real estate in New York. And sometimes I just make things up. I'd say he's a chef. But it was always funny, because it was a running joke between me and my dad that when I was growing up I couldn't tell people, because nobody else had a dad like that. And so I felt like they would either not believe me, or I would sound ridiculous. And they just wouldn't understand. But he had never had a problem with me saying to anyone what he does is that he gambles.
当时我会说，嗯，他现在没做具体什么事，但他在纽约有房产。有时我只是编造一些东西。我会说他是厨师。但这总是很有趣，因为我和我爸爸之间有一个持续的笑话，那就是我长大时不能告诉别人，因为没有别人的爸爸像那样。所以我感觉他们要么不相信我，要么我会显得很荒唐。他们只是不会理解。但他从来没有对我告诉任何人他做什么——他赌博——感到困扰。
(HOST) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: When Joe moved to Las Vegas, his daughter was just entering high school. He raised her practically as a single parent, starting from the time she was born, when his ex-wife had a breakdown. It wasn't until they moved to Las Vegas that she says she really understood just how much her father gambled.
（主持人）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：当乔搬到拉斯维加斯时，他女儿刚上高中。他实际上是作为单亲家长养大了她，从她出生开始，当时他的前妻精神崩溃了。直到他们搬到拉斯维加斯，她说她才真正明白她父亲赌博的程度。
I guess what always blew me away in the beginning is we would walk in and everybody would know him. And they would know me too, because he would talk about me. And I would say to him, how do these people know you? I was amazed by that. And they would joke with him, and they'd say, are you back again? And they'd say, well, what do you need today? Because he would go in sometimes and he'd say I need a pool today.
我想最让我震惊的是刚开始时，我们走进去，每个人都认识他。他们也认识我，因为他会谈论我。我会对他说，这些人怎么认识你？我对此感到惊讶。他们会和他开玩笑，说，你又回来了？他们会说，你今天需要什么？因为他有时进去会说，我今天需要一个游泳池。
(INTERVIEWER) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: How much money does it take to build a pool?
（采访者）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：修一个游泳池要多少钱？
$20,000? I don't remember how--
20,000美元？我不记得是怎么——
(INTERVIEWER) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: How long did that take?
（采访者）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：那花了多长时间？
Literally 10 minutes, maybe. One, two, three. And that was it.
实际上10分钟，也许。一，二，三。就是这样。
(HOST) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: But as much as she knows her dad's wins, she remembers the times when they were broke. Really broke.
（主持人）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：但尽管她知道她父亲的赢钱，她也记得他们破产的时候。真的很穷。
We would have to search for quarters on the floor. And my uncle-- this was really funny-- to buy a hamburger, or something like that.
我们不得不满地找硬币。而我叔叔——这真的很有趣——去买个汉堡之类的东西。
(INTERVIEWER) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: Search for quarters on the floor in your uncle's--
（采访者）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：满地找硬币在你叔叔的——
Yeah. He would search. We would pick them up. And I would go and get a hamburger. But that was in the very beginning. I mean, even when things are really bad he can always find a way out of it. And even I would be amazed. Because I would say to him, there's no way-- that how are you gonna do that? And he'd say, don't worry. We'll find a way. And there was always a way. And he can just laugh about it.
是的。他会找。我们会捡起来。然后我去买个汉堡。但那是在刚开始的时候。我的意思是，即使在事情变得非常糟糕时，他总能找到出路。甚至连我都会感到惊讶。因为我会对他说，没门——你怎么做得到？他说，别担心。我们会找到办法的。而且总有办法。他可以笑着谈论它。
Which airline are you going to?
你们要去哪家航空公司？
Southwest.
西南航空。
Southwest?
西南航空？
(HOST) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: It's noon, and Joe has $1,100. The limo business has been steady for hours. It's a good time for business, but Joe wants to take a break to call his daughter.
（主持人）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：现在是中午，乔有1100美元。豪华轿车生意忙了好几个小时。这是做生意的好时候，但乔想休息一下给女儿打电话。
I talk to her like five times a day.
我和她一天通五次话。
(HOST) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: It's late night in Israel. He just wants to hear about her day.
（主持人）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：以色列现在是深夜。他只想听听她的一天。
Hi, honey. It's me. I just called to say hi.
嗨，亲爱的。是我。我只是打电话来说声嗨。
(INTERVIEWER) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: So what's happened since your daughter is gone?
（采访者）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：那你女儿走了以后发生了什么？
Well, that's when I started to work. I never worked while she was here. This like filled up my void, maybe, in a way. [INAUDIBLE] just think about it. I miss her so much. When I see her it's like-- it's the greatest feeling in the world. And we're at the airport now. This is zero level. I'm going to go upstairs and see how busy it is-- if people are looking for rooms.
嗯，那是时候我开始工作了。她在的时候我从来不工作。这可能填补了我的空虚。我太想她了。当我看到她时，就像……这是世界上最伟大的感觉。我们现在在机场。这是零层。我要上楼看看有多忙——看人们是否在找房间。
(HOST) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: It's 1:30 PM and we're up to $1,300. We've just dropped off yet another ride at the airport. And for a little variety, Joe says he's going to show me how he also sells hotel rooms. These are hotel rooms the casinos give him for free because he gambles so much.
（主持人）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：现在是下午1:30，我们有1300美元。我们刚刚在机场又送了一趟。为了增加点花样，乔说他要给我展示他是如何卖掉酒店房间的。这些是赌场因为他赌博多而免费给他的酒店房间。
So I got to make it seem like I'm just walking casual. [whistling]
所以我得表现得像我只是随便走走。（吹口哨）
(HOST) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: Joe's carefully checking out a middle-aged couple in shorts and tennis shoes. Just as he's about to approach them-- [phone ringing]-- we're interrupted.
（主持人）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：乔正在仔细观察一对穿着短裤和网球鞋的中年夫妇。就在他要接近他们时——（电话铃声响起）——我们被打断了。
Hi. This is Joe. Oh. How you doing, Dave? What's up?
嗨。我是乔。噢。你好吗，戴夫？怎么了？
(HOST) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: A lucrative job has come up. He says some high roller wants to charter his limo for three hours. For three hours? Did you tell him it's $75 an hour, though?
（主持人）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：一个有利可图的工作出现了。他说有个大金主想包他的豪华轿车三小时。三个小时？你告诉他每小时75美元了吗？
(HOST) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: Joe says these guys are seldom big tippers, but it's worth the gamble. This customer-- a handsome, mid-thirties Middle Easterner-- says no recording, please. So Joe tells me to take a break, and he'll catch up with me when he's done.
（主持人）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：乔说这些家伙很少给大额小费，但这值得冒险。这个客户——一位英俊的、三十多岁的中东人——说请不要录音。所以乔告诉我休息一下，他做完后会回来找我。
Since my family lost their homes when the Jews took over Israel--
自从犹太人占领以色列，我家失去了房子后——
(HOST) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: It's 5:00 PM, and I have no idea how much money Joe has. When we reconnect he looks exhausted, but hyped up. Since I left him he's finished with the charter, been to the casino to gamble, where he won $500. But there's more. He's anxious to tell me about how he's ended the day.
（主持人）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：现在是下午5点，我不知道乔有多少钱。当我们重新连接时，他看起来精疲力竭，但很亢奋。我离开他后，他完成了包车，去了赌场玩，赢了500美元。但还有更多。他急切地想告诉我他是怎么结束这一天的。
(INTERVIEWER) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: So tell me this again. So this guy at the end of the day-- you thought this was gonna be the end of the day.
（采访者）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：那你再告诉我一遍。这个人在一天结束时——你以为这会是结束。
I just asked him-- I asked him-- I said to him, where are you from? So he says, Lebanon. And I said, oh, I speak Arabic. I said, I was born in Baghdad. I was really born in Baghdad, Iraq.
我只是问他——我问他——我对他说了，你是哪里人？他说，黎巴嫩。我说，噢，我会说阿拉伯语。我说，我出生在巴格达。我真的是出生在伊拉克巴格达。
(HOST) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: What Joe didn't tell the guy is that he's Jewish.
（主持人）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：乔没告诉那个人的是他是犹太人。
I said, are you Muslim? He says, yes. Yes. I said, oh, those Jews-- I said, what they're doing is terrible to the Palestinians. And then he just-- his adrenaline just started going. He wanted to go out with me tonight. He wanted to hire the car for five hours tonight. And then I said, no. I said, I'm too tired. So he says, well, I'll call you tomorrow. I said, fine. He's like buddy-buddy. But he gave me 500 bucks. I said, all right. That's what I call a perfect day. You go out with like 32 bucks, you go home with two grand.
我说，你是穆斯林吗？他说，是的。是的。我说，噢，那些犹太人——我说，他们对巴勒斯坦人做的事情太可怕了。然后他只是……他的肾上腺素飙升。他今晚想和我出去。他想今晚包车五个小时。然后我说，不。我说，我太累了。他说，好吧，我明天打给你。我说，好的。他就像哥们一样。但他给了我500块。我说，好吧。这就是我所谓的完美的一天。你从32块左右开始，你带着两千块回家。
(HOST) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: As we take off, Joe's still hanging on to today's winnings in a wad of bills, folded up like it's a double cheeseburger in one of his hands on the steering wheel.
（主持人）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：当我们起飞时，乔仍然紧紧抓着今天的赢利，那一大把钞票在他开车的一只手里折叠着，就像个双层芝士汉堡。
$230 he gave me as a tip, which is not bad.
他给了我230美元作为小费，这还不错。
(HOST) MARY BETH KIRCHNER: But think of it. If Joe just worked five days a week, making $2,000 a day, and never lost it back, that'd be a half million dollars a year.
（主持人）玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔：但想一想。如果乔每天工作五天，每天赚2000美元，而且从不输回去，那一年就是五十万美元。
It's a wonderful country. [laughing]
这是一个美好的国家。（大笑）
Mary Beth Kirchner lives in Washington, DC. Coming up, when the creator of the universe starts from scratch. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔住在华盛顿特区。接下来，当宇宙的创造者从零开始。那一幕将在一分钟后从芝加哥公共广播电台继续播出。
This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, of course, we choose a theme, and bring you a variety of different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's program-- Starting from Scratch. Stories of people starting over, with all the vulnerability and rawness that comes with starting from nothing.
《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯。当然，我们每周都在节目中选择一个主题，并为您带来各种各样的关于该主题的故事。今天的节目——“从零开始”。讲述人们从零开始、带着从一无所有开始所伴随的脆弱和原始的故事。
We've arrived at Act Three. The first starting from scratch. Well, before there was money, or gambling, or TV, or puppies, or even the idea of before, there was this story about when everything started from scratch. Here's Jonathan Goldstein.
我们进入了第三幕。第一次从零开始。好吧，在有钱、赌博、电视、小狗，甚至“之前”这个概念出现之前，有这样一个关于一切如何从零开始的故事。这是乔纳森·戈德斯坦。
In the beginning, when Adam was first created, he spent whole days rubbing his face in the grass. He picked his ear until it bled. Tried to fit his fist in his mouth. And yanked out tufts of his own hair. At one point, he tried to pinch his own eyes out in order to examine them. And God had to step in.
在起初，当亚当刚被创造出来时，他整天都在草地上摩擦他的脸。他挖耳朵直到流血。试图把拳头塞进嘴里。并拔掉自己的头发。有一次，他试图挖出自己的眼睛来检查它们。上帝不得不介入。
Looking down at Adam, God must have felt a bit weird about the whole thing. It must have been something like eating at a cafeteria table all by yourself, when a stranger suddenly sits down opposite you. But it's a stranger who you have created. And he is eating a macaroni salad that you've also created. And you have been sitting at the table all by yourself for over 100 billion years. And yet still, you have nothing to talk about.
俯视着亚当，上帝对整件事一定感到有些奇怪。这一定就像一个人在食堂桌子旁独自用餐，而一个陌生人突然坐到你对面一样。但他是一个你创造的陌生人。他在吃着你创造的通心粉沙拉。而你已经在桌旁独自坐了超过1000亿年。然而，你依然没有话可谈。
It was pitiful the way Adam looked up into the sky and squinted. Before he created Adam, God must have been lonely. Now he was still lonely. And so was Adam.
亚当看向天空眯着眼睛的样子真是可怜。在创造亚当之前，上帝一定是孤独的。现在他仍然孤独。亚当也是。
Then came Eve. Since the Garden of Eden was the very first village, and since every village needs a mayor as well as a village idiot, it broke down in this way. Eve. Mayor. Adam. Village idiot. And that is the way it was from the very beginning. Sometimes when Adam would start to speak Eve would get all hopeful that he was about to impart something important and smart. But he would only say stuff like, little things are really great, because you can put them in your hand as well as in your mouth.
接着夏娃出现了。由于伊甸园是第一个村庄，而每个村庄既需要村长也需要村里的傻子，事情就这样分工了。夏娃，村长。亚当，村里的傻子。从一开始就是这样。有时当亚当开始说话时，夏娃会充满希望，以为他要传达什么重要而聪明的东西。但他只会说诸如“小东西真的很棒，因为你既可以把它们放在手里，也可以放进嘴里”之类的话。
Eve would ponder how one minute she was not there or anywhere, and now she was. Adam would ponder nothing. In her dreams Eve danced in the tops of trees. Her beautiful thoughts flew out of her ears and lit up the sky like fireflies. And there were all kinds of people to talk to and hug. And then she would hear snoring. She would wake up and there would be Adam, his yokel face pressed right against hers. His dog food breath blowing right up her nostrils.
夏娃会沉思她如何一分钟前不存在或不在任何地方，而现在她在了。亚当什么都不沉思。梦中夏娃在树顶跳舞。她美丽的思绪从耳朵里飞出来，像萤火虫一样照亮天空。有各种各样的人可以交谈和拥抱。然后她会听到打呼噜声。她醒来，亚当就在那里，他那乡下人的脸紧贴着她的脸。他的狗粮味呼吸直冲她的鼻孔。
Eve stared up at the sky. Adam draped his arm across her chest, and brought his knee up onto her stomach. God, watching in heaven, feared for Adam's broken heart as though the whole universe depended on it. Adam was close to the animals and spent all day talking to them. Except for God, Eve had no one. She would complain to the Lord any chance she got.
夏娃盯着天空。亚当把胳膊搭在她的胸口，膝盖顶在她的肚子上。在天上的上帝，为亚当破碎的心感到恐惧，好像整个宇宙都取决于它。亚当与动物很亲近，整天与它们交谈。除了上帝，夏娃谁也没有。她一有机会就向主抱怨。
Adam is a nimrod, she would say. And the Lord would remain silent. God was the best and all that, and she loved the hell out of him. But when it came to trash talk, he was of no use. Adam was constantly trying to impress her. Look what I have made, he said one bright morning, his hands cupped together. Eve looked into his hands. She pulled away and shrieked. Adam was holding giraffe feces. I've sculpted it, said Adam. It is for the Lord. He opened his hands wide to reveal to her a tiny little giraffe with a crooked neck.
“亚当是个白痴，”她说。而主保持沉默。上帝是最好的，诸如此类，她爱死他了。但当谈到垃圾话时，他没用。亚当不断地想给她留下深刻印象。他杯子一样双手合十，“看我做了什么，”他一个明亮的早晨说。夏娃看着他的手。她退缩并尖叫起来。亚当拿着长颈鹿粪便。“我雕刻了它，”亚当说。“这是给主的。”他张开双手，向她展示了一只脖子歪斜的小长颈鹿。
On some days Adam galloped about exploring. His hair was wiry, and when it got sweaty it hung down in his eyes. Adam was cute this way. On one such day he saw a snake. Adam made the snake's acquaintance by accidentally stepping on his back. Wow, that's smart, said the snake through gritted teeth.
有些日子亚当到处奔跑探索。他的头发呈铁丝状，出汗时垂在眼睛里。亚当这样很可爱。在这样的一天，他看到了一条蛇。亚当通过不小心踩到它的背结识了这条蛇。“哇，真聪明，”蛇咬牙切齿地说。
Their eyes locked. And in that very moment the snake concluded that, indeed, Adam was a lummox. And that as king of the Earth, his reign would very soon end. There was a new sheriff in town, and it was he. It was no longer the story of Adam, but the story of the snake. He could tell all of this just by simply looking into his idiot eyes.
他们的目光锁定。就在那一刻，蛇断定，亚当确实是个笨蛋。而且作为地球之王，他的统治很快就会结束。镇上来了一个新警长，就是它。这不再是亚当的故事，而是蛇的故事。它只需看着他那愚蠢的眼睛就能断定这一切。
I've seen you around with another one like you, he said to Adam. But instead of the dead legless snake between the legs she has chaos there. That's Eve, said Adam, all animated. I named her that myself. God made her from out of my rib. He showed the snake the scar on his side.
“我见过你和另一个像你一样的在一起，”它对亚当说。“但她的两腿之间不是那个死掉的无腿蛇，她那里有混乱。”“那是夏娃，”亚当很激动地说。“那名字是我自己取的。上帝是用我的肋骨创造了她。”他向蛇展示了侧面的伤疤。
The snake looked at him in silence. The idea of Adam-- Adam the shlemiel, Adam the fool-- being God's favorite was enough to give the snake a migraine. You weren't at all like I imagined, the snake said. I thought you'd be closer to the ground. More pliant. Greener. I tried to explain to God that to make you balanced up on your hind legs was architecturally unsound. I don't know why I bother.
蛇沉默地看着他。亚当——那个傻瓜，亚当那个蠢货——成为上帝最爱的人的想法足以让蛇偏头痛。“你一点也不像我想象的那样，”蛇说。“我以为你会更贴近地面。更柔顺。更绿。我试着向上帝解释，让你这种生物在后腿上平衡在建筑结构上是不合理的。我不知道为什么要操这份心。”
Adam sat and listened wide-eyed. Eve hadn't the patience to sit and chat like this. So when the snake suggested they get into the habit of meeting every once in a while to talk Adam was very excited to do so. As they lazed on their backs staring up at the sky the snake would brag about how he was older than the whole world, and that he used to pal around with God in the dark back before creation.
亚当瞪大眼睛坐着听。夏娃没有耐心坐在这里闲聊。所以当蛇建议他们养成偶尔见面谈谈的习惯时，亚当非常兴奋地照做了。当他们懒洋洋地躺着盯着天空时，蛇会吹嘘它比全世界还要老，在创造之前，它曾在黑暗中与上帝相伴。
He said that in the darkness, it was a truer, freer air time. That in the darkness was the good old days. He told Adam that back in the very beginning he had all kinds of thoughts on how to make the Garden of Eden a better place, but that God was just too stubborn to listen to reason. Make the earth out of sugar, I told him. Instead of stingers, give bees lips they can kiss you with.
它说在黑暗中，有一种更真实、更自由的空气时间。在黑暗中才是好日子。它告诉亚当，在最开始时，它有各种关于如何让伊甸园变得更好的想法，但上帝太固执，听不进理由。“我告诉他，用糖制作地球。与其给蜜蜂螫针，不如给它们可以亲吻你的嘴唇。”
Adam didn't always agree with the snake. In fact, a lot of what the snake said went straight over his head. But there was still something about him that made him get into a very particular mood. He made the world feel bigger. Sometimes when Adam was with Eve, sitting there in icy silence, he would think to himself, I sure could go for a good dose of snake.
亚当并不总是同意蛇的观点。事实上，蛇说的很多话他根本听不懂。但它身上确实有一些东西让他进入了一种非常特别的情绪。它让世界感觉更大。有时当亚当和夏娃在一起，坐在冰冷的沉默中时，他会想，“我一定要多吸点蛇的智慧。”
You would think that after all the time they spent together the snake would finally find it within himself to start liking Adam just a little bit. But instead, he only grew to hate him more. He took to comforting himself with thoughts of Adam's wife, Eve. From what he heard from Adam, she was hot and smart. Often he would imagine running into her, and the instant synergy they would have. Adam neglected to tell me how leggy you are, he would say, wrapping himself around her calf.
你会认为在他们在一起度过这么多时间后，蛇终于能开始喜欢亚当一点点了。但相反，它只会越来越恨他。它开始用关于亚当的妻子夏娃的想法来安慰自己。从它从亚当那里听到的，她既性感又聪明。它经常想象遇到她，以及他们会有的即时默契。“亚当忽略了告诉我你是多么多腿，”它会想象说着，缠绕在她的脚踝上。
The snake had no idea what he looked like. He was hairless, bucktoothed, four inches tall, and he spoke with a lisp. Adam had the IQ of a coconut husk, but he was still human. The snake, in his arrogance, was unable to grasp this, and so he daydreamed. Sometimes I think you were watching me, the snake imagine saying to Eve, because I felt like there were ribbons wrapped around me. Ribbons made of raw pork intestines. I would turn around to catch you sneaking a peek at me from behind a tree, but all I'd see were the hedgehogs which mocked me. Come my dear. Let us eat from the tree of knowledge.
蛇不知道自己看起来像什么。它秃头，龅牙，四英寸高，口齿不清。亚当的智商像个椰子壳，但他毕竟是人类。蛇在傲慢中无法理解这一点，所以它做白日梦。有时我以为你在看着我，蛇想象着对夏娃说，因为我感觉有丝带缠绕着我。丝带是由生猪肠制成的。我会转身捕捉到你从树后偷窥我，但我看到的只是嘲笑我的刺猬。来吧，亲爱的。让我们吃知识树的果子。
On Eve's very first day Adam explained to her the rules of the garden just the way God had explained them to him. He had lifted his head up and had made his back stiff. He had spoken the way a radio broadcaster from the 1940s would. Another kind of woman-- someone softer than Eve-- might have found this charming. He explained that except for the tree of knowledge every tree in the garden was theirs to eat from.
在夏娃的第一天，亚当就像上帝向他解释的那样向她解释了花园的规则。他昂着头，背部僵硬。他说话的方式像1940年代的广播员。另一种女人——比夏娃更温柔的人——可能会觉得这很有魅力。他解释说，除了知识树，花园里的每一棵树都可以吃。
I am a fan of the pear, Adam said. It is not unlike an apple whose head craves God. Tell me more about this tree of knowledge, said Eve. She enjoyed the sound of it-- the tree of knowledge. It sounded very poetic. There's not much to tell, said Adam. If we eat from it we will die.
“我是梨的粉丝，”亚当说。“它和苹果没什么不同，头脑渴望上帝。”“多告诉我一些关于这棵知识树的事，”夏娃说。她喜欢它的声音——知识树。听起来很有诗意。“没什么好说的，”亚当说。“如果我们吃了它，我们就会死。”
From then on Eve talked about the tree of knowledge all the time. It was tree of knowledge this, and tree of knowledge that. It's like it wasn't a tree at all, but a movie star. Sometimes she would just stand by the tree and stare at it. It was on such an occasion that she met the snake.
从那时起，夏娃一直谈论知识树。知识树这，知识树那。就好像它根本不是一棵树，而是一位电影明星。有时她会站在树旁盯着它。就是在这样的场合下，她遇到了蛇。
When Eve first caught sight of him she brought her hand to her mouth and gasped. She had seen some repulsive animals in her day. A booby that percolated her vomit to just beneath her tonsils. A dingo that instilled in her a sublime sense of nature's cruelty. And a deathwatch beetle that filled her with existential dread. But still, there was something about the snake that made her realize in a flash that the world was anywhere from 60% to 80% oilier than she would have ever imagined.
当夏娃第一次看到它时，她用手捂住嘴倒吸一口冷气。她在她的日子里见过一些令人作呕的动物。一种把呕吐物渗滤到扁桃体下方的鲣鸟。一种在她心中灌输了对自然残酷感的崇高感的澳洲野犬。还有一种让她充满存在主义恐惧的埋葬虫。但即便如此，关于蛇的某些东西让她瞬间意识到，世界比她想象的油腻了60%到80%。
Hi, said the snake. In the mood for some fruit of knowledge? It's fruity. We were told not to eat from that tree or else we would die, said Eve. Die? What an ignorant thing to say, said the snake, all chewing on a blade of grass on the side of his mouth. If there is an escape hatch from paradise then it isn't really paradise, is it? The snake made interesting points. That appealed to Eve. He could see he was making an impression.
“嗨，”蛇说。“有心情吃点知识之果吗？它是果味的。”“我们被告知不要吃那棵树上的东西，否则我们会死，”夏娃说。“死？多么无知的话，”蛇说，嘴里嚼着草叶。“如果天堂有逃生舱，那它就不是真正的天堂，对吧？”蛇提出了有趣的观点。这吸引了夏娃。它能看出它给她留下了深刻印象。
All I'm saying is to give it a try. Many things will be made immediately clear to you once you partake. I could talk about it all day and you still won't get it. You have a right to at least try it, right? I'm not saying go out and eat an entire fruit. Have a nibble. A nibble isn't really eating, is it?
“我只是说试一试。一旦你参与，许多事情会立刻变得清晰。我可以谈论它一整天，你还是不会懂。你至少有权试一试，对吧？我不是说让你出去吃整个果子。尝一口。尝一口并不算是真正吃，对吧？”
Eve found arguing semantics exhilarating. She looked at the tree. The way the sun shined through its leaves was beautiful. Everything seemed to point to nibble the fruit. Then the snake said, think about it. Does God want companions who can think for themselves, or does he want a bunch of lackeys and yes men? Wouldn't God want a few surprises?
夏娃觉得争论语义学令人振奋。她看着树。阳光透过叶子照射的方式很美。一切似乎都在指向尝尝那个果子。然后蛇说，“想想看。上帝想要会思考的同伴，还是想要一堆应声虫和唯唯诺诺的人？上帝难道不想要一些惊喜吗？”
It would seem to me that God's telling you not to eat the fruit was just a test to see if you could think for yourselves, to see if you could exist as equals to God. The day you taste the fruit is the day God will no longer be lonely. At least give it a lick. Eve looked at the fruit, then she looked at the snake. Then, slowly, she parted her lips and pushed out her tongue-- all wet, and warm, and uncertain.
“在我看来，上帝让你不要吃那个果子只是个测试，看看你们是否会思考，看看你们是否能作为上帝的平等存在。你品尝果子的那一天，就是上帝不再孤独的一天。至少舔一下。”夏娃看着果子，然后看着蛇。然后，慢慢地，她分开了嘴唇，吐出了舌头——湿漉漉、温暖且不确定。
She ran its tip along the smooth flesh of the fruit. The snake smiled. Has anyone died? he asked. Now take a tiny little nibble. Just a speck. Just to see. The fruit was squishy and tart. She smushed it around in her mouth. She squinted her eyes. It was a bit like trying on new glasses. It was a bit like an amylnitrate popper. It was a bit like a big wet kiss on the lips, right at first when you weren't sure if you wanted to be kissed or not. She felt 1,000 little feet kicking at her uterus.
她沿着果子光滑的果肉滑动舌尖。蛇笑了。“有人死了吗？”它问。“现在再尝一小口。只是一点点。只是为了看看。”果子在她的嘴里滑腻而酸涩。她在嘴里搅动它。她眯起眼睛。这有点像尝试新眼镜。这有点像亚硝酸异戊酯（一种毒品）。这有点像嘴唇上的一个巨大的湿吻，刚开始你不确定是想被亲还是不想。她感觉到1000只小脚在踢她的子宫。
The idea of her own nudity, as well as Adam's, had always felt more like a Nordic coed health spa thing. Now, with the fruit of knowledge, it felt more like a Rio de Janeiro carnival thing. Her breasts felt like water balloons filled with blueberry jam and birds. Her nipples were like lit matchsticks. Her thighs, the way they squished against each other, were like scissors cutting through velour.
她对自己以及亚当裸体的想法，一直感觉更像是北欧学生的健康水疗。现在，有了知识之果，它感觉更像是里约热内卢的嘉年华。她的乳房感觉就像装满蓝莓酱和鸟的水球。她的乳头就像点燃的火柴。她的大腿，它们挤压在一起的方式，就像剪刀划过丝绒。
With her lips still glistening in tree of knowledge fruit juice, she ran off to find Adam. The snake watched her as he chewed on his slimy blade of grass. And as she receded into the distance, he thought something along the lines of, now that's what I'm talking about.
嘴唇上仍然闪烁着知识树果汁，她跑去找亚当。蛇一边嚼着粘糊糊的草叶一边看着她。当她消失在远处时，它想着诸如“那才是我想要的”之类的话。
Kiss me Adam, said Eve. Taste my lips. Adam, like any lummox truly worth his salt, could smell the minutest trace of knowledge coming his way. And thus, he knew how to avoid it like the plague. But yet, there was also this. Eve had never sought him out in the middle of the day before just to kiss him. It felt like a very lucky thing. When he took her in his arms he told her that he loved her with his whole entire heart. He closed his eyes tightly and brought his lips to hers. Then he squinted. Then it started to rain, and Eve began to cry.
“亲我，亚当，”夏娃说。“尝尝我的嘴唇。”亚当，像任何真正值得称赞的笨蛋一样，能闻到知识的微弱气息向他袭来。因此，他知道如何像躲避瘟疫一样躲避它。但即便如此，还是有这个。夏娃以前从未在白天专门为了亲他而找他。这感觉像一件非常幸运的事情。当他把她抱在怀里时，他告诉她他全心全意地爱她。他紧紧闭上眼睛，把嘴唇贴向她。然后他眯起眼睛。然后开始下雨，夏娃开始哭泣。
During the darkest days ahead, with the fratricides and whatnot, Adam would often think back to his brief time in Eden. As he became an old man, he would talk about the garden more and more. A couple of times he had even tried to find his way back there, but he very soon became lost. He didn't try too hard anyway. He didn't want to bother God any more than he already had. When Adam met someone that he really liked, he would say, I so wish you could have been there. It didn't seem fair to him that he was the one that got to be in Eden.
在未来的最黑暗的日子里，伴随着弑亲之类的事件，亚当经常会回想他在伊甸园的短暂时光。随着他变老，他越来越多地谈论那个花园。有几次他甚至尝试找路回去，但很快就迷路了。无论如何他也没怎么努力。他不想比已经打扰到的那样更多地打扰上帝。当亚当遇到一个他真正喜欢的人时，他会说，“真希望你能在那儿。他觉得得到那个在伊甸园的机会很不公平。”
This sunset isn't bad, he'd say. But the sunsets in Eden, they burned your nose hairs. They made your ears bleed. He couldn't even explain it right. When you ate the fruit in Eden it was like eating God, he would say. And God was delicious. When you wanted him you just grabbed him. Now when he ate fruit he can only taste what was not there.
“这日落还行，”他会说。“但伊甸园的日落，它们能烧焦你的鼻毛。它们让你的耳朵流血。”他甚至无法解释清楚。他说，“当你在伊甸园吃果子时，就像在吃上帝。上帝很美味。当你想要他时，你就抓住他。”现在当他吃果子时，他只能尝到不存在的东西。
But it wasn't all bad. After Eden Eve became much gentler with Adam. After getting them both cast out she decided to try as hard as she could to give Adam her love. She knew it was the very least she could do. She sometimes even wondered if that was why God had sent the snake to her in the first place. Adam would tell his grandkids, his great-grandkids, and his great-great-grandkids about how he and Nana Eve had spent their early days in a beautiful garden naked and frolicking. And the kids would say, eww.
但这并非全是坏事。在伊甸园之后，夏娃对亚当温柔多了。在将两人都赶出之后，她决定尽她最大的努力给亚当她的爱。她知道这是她唯一能做的。她有时甚至想知道这是否就是上帝最初把蛇送到她那里的原因。亚当会告诉他的孙辈、曾孙辈和玄孙辈关于他和夏娃奶奶是如何在美丽的果园里赤身裸体、嬉戏度过早年时光的。孩子们会说，“好恶心”。
The children would swarm into the house like a carpet of ants. The youngest ones would head straight for Adam, lifting his shirt to examine his belly for the umpteenth time. They smoothed their hands across his flesh and marveled. Where is grandpa's belly button? they all asked. He stared at the children. They were all his children. And as they slid their little hands across his blank stomach, he wondered what it was like to be a kid.
孩子们会像蚂蚁一样成群结队地涌进屋里。最小的会径直走向亚当，掀起他的衬衫，无数次地检查他的肚脐。他们把手抚过他的皮肤，惊叹不已。“爷爷的肚脐在哪里？”他们都问。他盯着孩子们。他们都是他的孩子。当他们把小手滑过他平坦的肚子时，他想知道作为一个孩子是什么感觉。
Jonathan Goldstein. This story appears in his book where he rewrites bible stories, called Ladies and Gentlemen, the Bible. Jonathan is also the writer and host of the really wonderful podcast Heavyweight.
乔纳森·戈德斯坦。这个故事出现在他的书里，他在书中重写了圣经故事，题为《女士们先生们，圣经》。乔纳森也是非常精彩的播客《重量级》（Heavyweight）的编剧和主持人。
Our program was produced today by Wendy Dorr and myself with Alex Blumberg, Diane Cook, David Kestenbaum, and Starlee Kine. Production help for today's show from Todd Bachmann, Jane Marie, Aaron Scott, and Alvin Melathe. Mixing help today from Katherine Rae Mondo. Our technical director is Matt Tierney. Special thanks today to Mr. George [? Lara. ?] Thanks also to Kevin Scully, Dave [INAUDIBLE], and Tony Mancini. Some of the funding for Mary Beth Kirchner's story about the gambler came from the Corporation for Public Broadcasting's radio fund.
今天的节目由温迪·多尔（Wendy Dorr）和我制作，亚历克斯·布隆伯格（Alex Blumberg）、黛安·库克（Diane Cook）、大卫·克里斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）和斯塔莉·凯恩（Starlee Kine）参与。今天节目的制作协助来自托德·巴赫曼（Todd Bachmann）、简·玛丽（Jane Marie）、亚伦·斯科特（Aaron Scott）和阿尔文·梅拉特（Alvin Melathe）。今天的混音协助来自凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多（Katherine Rae Mondo）。我们的技术总监是马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）。今天特别感谢乔治·拉拉先生（George Lara）。还要感谢凯文·斯卡利（Kevin Scully）、戴夫（Dave）和托尼·曼奇尼（Tony Mancini）。玛丽·贝丝·基什内尔关于赌徒的故事的部分资金来自公共广播公司（Corporation for Public Broadcasting）的广播基金。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to any of our over 600 shows for absolutely free. Or if you want to download those shows you can get our app. This American Life is distributed by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia, who got all angry this week when I told him that we were going to be putting a story about puppies onto the Public Radio satellite.
我们的网站 thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以免费收听我们超过600个节目中的任何一个。或者如果你想下载那些节目，你可以获取我们的应用程序。《美国生活》由公共广播交流中心（PRX）分发。一如既往，感谢我们节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生，当我本周告诉他我们将要把一个关于小狗的故事放到公共广播卫星上时，他非常生气。
You'd ask us to give up six megaschlucks of gooberschnapp to put just puppies on there?
“你让我们放弃六兆赫的传输带宽，就为了放一堆小狗？”
Well, yeah. I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
嗯，是的。我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。